We think that knowledge is an endless
accumulation. You add to
what came before—which we do—and it never goes away; you keep adding more
and more and more and it builds up and
it's all getting greater and greater.
Obviously not quite true. We think that
these silly people from the 17th century,
or the medieval folks or whatever,
are just not as smart as we are. That
that's why they forgot these things.
What's why they lost the recipe for
concrete. How could they lose it?! They must have been idiots! So we think that
we're wiser than people were in the past.
As Donald Rumsfeld would say, "These are
the unknown unknowns." When something is forgotten
we're unaware that it exists. So we have
no knowledge that, "Oh, we lost the recipe
for concrete." Maybe we see this dome and we go, "Oh man, how did they do that?" But we
don't know. We don't know what's missing because it's
missing. Abandonment, letting a knowledge
or technology go is a kind of filter.
It might not be a good filter, but sometimes
it might be a necessary filter.
Rediscovery, then—which is also selective—is another filter. So things are getting
filtered now twice. We find the future,
our own future, the future of everyone,
sometimes we find it in the past. Rather
than looking at the here and now and
looking forward, we should maybe turn
around and see what happened before that
we missed.
So to go forwards, sometimes we first
have to go back. That's the end.